e
e e
I realized maybe maybe citizens want to
know
City all right our subcommittee is all
present we had um a little bit of a
weather delay there but we'll we'll get
started
um I want to start out by trying to
uh think about what we might accomplish
today and uh I'll start with saying I
think the reason that the
chairman put together this subcommittee
is that when we were listening to the
questions during the public hearing
there was some of them seemed to be
focusing on details of the bill and
saying well is this necessary is this
part necessary and I think he had an
idea that there might be a way to amend
it that it would be broadly accepted
cable um as I've worked on it as I've
done some more reading I'm not sure that
that's where we're headed at all
um
so I think we'll put that aside as a
goal um certainly what when we come to
the end and we make our subcommittee
recommendation it's whatever we we
decide to recommend uh but I don't think
that's where we want to head I also so
don't think it's a productive use of
this committee if we're let's say 2 two
on the recommendation to debate it here
so that we can tell the full committee
that oh we had a debate and we didn't
come to any
conclusion however um
what has occurred to me in the time
between the public hearing and now is
that I
think I didn't have a real clear
understanding of issue at the end of
that meeting and in the time between
then I've traded some emails with people
I've read some information about um
federal and state law I've looked at the
rules that we talked about and at least
I think I'm coming to a better
understanding of where we are today than
what I was
thinking last week and if this
subcommittee accomplish that if it we at
least can all agree that this is this is
where we are today even if we agree or
disagree on what where we should go
forward I think that would be an
accomplishment so that's kind of where I
want to start and I'll start by talking
and then you're already talking I I'll
I'll continue by talking and hopefully
I'll stop talking soon enough
so this is what what I heard yet last
week in the hearing is that there were
two
issues um that needed to be addressed
the first was a specific issue about
that happened at Plymouth state with
raas that were employees and there and
maybe shouldn't have been and there was
no way to resolve the issue the second
one which is a little more broader in
general is that there's a a gap or maybe
even a conf lict
between the way the US Department of
Labor would look at a situation and the
way New Hampshire Department of Labor
would look at a situation so very
quickly my updated understanding I'll
start with the second is yes it's true
uh US Department of Labor has one way of
looking at this and it's not exactly the
same way New Hampshire Department of
Labor is but I think it's a lot closer
than what I
understood a week ago um and the answer
is if you go to the US Department of
Labor and you say we have this ra um and
there's some concern is it an employee
the answer from US Department of Labor
will be well it
depends and it depends on there there's
a list in their Manual of ways that that
ra might be compensated and if it fits
some of them but not others then they're
not an employee
presumably if it's a little different
then they will be so it's not a
clear-cut answer on that side if we go
to the State Department of Labor the
answer will be it depends and it won't
be it's not exactly the same factors and
it's not the same
process but um and hypothetically yes
there could be the federal comes to one
conclusion state comes to the opposite
but at least as far as I can tell on a
practical basis that's not necessarily
happening I'm not sure we have actual
conflicts out there where the federal
government says one thing the state says
another and and the two can't
meet
um so I'll skip ahead to then the
Plymouth State situation seemed to be
just such an
example and what I've learned about
there is that was and
that as I understand it and and if I'm
wrong shake your head vigorously uh the
rule change it this whole thing must be
about 10 years ago that it came up
because it looked like the rule change
was submitted in 2015 approved in
2016 um
and yeah yes and in fact
the wait this isn't a public hearing so
you could either if you're going to be
answering a lot you could sit at one of
the one of the regular chairs and that
way we
have just to and so for anyone who may
not um know I'm Danielle Albert with the
New Hampshire Department of Labor so the
rule change I believe that you're
referencing is in relation to New
Hampshire's administrative rules at lab
805 um specifically provision 805
505 uh the the entirety of that rule
went into effect at a date that I do not
recall but there was an amendment to
8055 that was approved and and published
through that whole gel car process I
want to say in October of this year oh
so that is it's very recent it's very
very recent now the rule itself is an it
has been around for some period of time
but the department amended that that
80505 section of the rule uh to address
a concern that we understood from the
University system in engaging with them
over the course of the uh PSU inspection
case um such that there is an Avenue or
mechanism available for any employer it
doesn't apply just to colleges or to
universities who has a
student um participating in in some kind
of practical experience program which is
what that whole section of rules is
outlining uh but also to allow that
student to hold a regular paying job at
the same time whereas the prior rule did
not allow for sort of a dual
relationship of that nature and kind of
coming to a college or university type
scenario if you have somebody who let's
say for example is an RA and they are in
an approved you know the ra position is
an approved practical experience program
they can do that for sub or no um can be
approved for sub minimum wage or no wage
uh but ALS maybe work in the bookstore
in the cafeteria for a regular paying
job making minimum wage they can hold
the the Dual roles without
issue and I'm just going to repeat some
of that because until you explained it
it was I didn't understand what the
issue at at Plymouth state was and this
was a case where the students in
question were definitely employees there
was no question about that because they
for example worked in the bookstore and
they received a wage for that payment
and the the issue was so they're also an
RA and how does that interact it's the
same entities involved but is it still
an employer employee relationship and
the rules after the change allowed you
to deal with that Nuance that it right
with with with the Nuance that addresses
the rule change I don't believe and I'm
looking at Miss preventure she can
correct me if my recollection is poor I
don't believe that the issue in the PSU
case was uh specifically that we had
students who were holding both roles the
Department's assessment of the ra
position as it was constructed in that
particular case was it kind of exceeded
um it walked into the realm of
employment um for a host of different
factors am I remembering that come
up I'm not on camera uh you probably
are they they control that upstairs but
I would assume they've put the camera
uh good morning um uh Katherine
preventure I serve as the chief
administrative officer of the University
system so um Miss alare is absolutely
correct the there was a rule change in
October
because when we learn more app um as a
result of the Plymouth inspection there
were all kinds of tentacles to to the
issue now let me if I can try to explain
the Plymouth
situation so
similar to the Dartmouth students
Plymouth Ras received a
stipend and they also received free room
and board and if if memory serves the
dartman students receive meal a l a meal
plant but not not
room so when you receiving a stipend
you're getting a W2 and you are an
employee but what also comes with that
you need to be tracking your hours we
need to ensure that minimum wage is paid
and I will
say I believe that this is an issue at
other colleges in the state that are
paying stipend and the RAS are not
tracking time which is when we went back
and relied on the federal the US do
guidelines that indicate raas in an
educational program are generally not
considered employees under F FS SL
SLA um I believe one of the someone else
had testified that that the is it
nlr I'm not going to get my alphabet sou
correct nlrb that that raas do have a
right under the
NL um B I'm sorry um to yes organize so
that conflict is in at the federal level
as well right they're
not generally required to follow
fsla and and the same thing would happen
here in New Hampshire I believe if this
bill were to pass that the
plrb would decide whether or not raas
wanted to
um
organized however I come back
to if Ras are employees and subject to
the New Hampshire time and wage law it's
my understanding they need to track
their
time um and we need to ensure that
they're paid minimum wage and that we
get um M messed then then there are
issues with free room and board right
how do we continue to provide free room
and board if that can't be part of the
compensation at least the room so in in
an effort to try to align the federal
guidelines with New Hampshire law this
is where we are I will tell you the the
it's my understanding the rule that was
adopted in
October would
provide a mechanism for any employer
college or university to apply for a
waiver applying for the waiver presumes
they're an employee otherwise you
wouldn't need to apply for
waiver um but we're I'm still not clear
on whether or not the waiver needs to be
filed or for every ra at every
institution every semester or whether
each institution could apply for the
waiver we're still not certain on on how
that mechanism will work and
um so that that's while that mechanism
is available I don't know what how
administratively that will roll out if
every ra every semester needs a wer
approved or whether they'd be
approved and so why don't we do that
last part first you can answer that in
reverse order okay so one as it relates
to um filing an application for it
waiver exemption it's it's um in these
circumstances the and the origin of it
if it's a helpful at all it stems from
RSA 27922 AA that's the statutory
provision from which these um learning
opportunity type programs stem from and
then the administrative rules that apply
are at 805 1 through 5 um I do not
believe that a any program whether
you're a university or some other type
of employer you wouldn't have to
necessarily file an application per
student you could file an application
for the program and maintain a list of
students and the department would be
looking for that to be updated you know
at least annually just to assure that
the program that the nature of the
program itself hasn't altered or changed
and again it's meant to be like a
practical experience there's some kind
of you know learning opportunity that
these student participants and honestly
there's a section that applies to
disabled individuals as well but we're
talking specifically about students here
um are engaging in so you know using
raas as an example mentorship leadership
community service you know could all be
um sort of practical could be
conceptualized as practical experience
uh that a student could have so in a
role like that if an application for the
program were filed the list of students
were maintained and or provided to the
department at request and was approved
by dep the department uh then the the uh
employer The Entity to whom these uh
raas are providing um said service that
entity can then be approved to pay
either sub minimum or no wage that's
what the statutory mechanism and the
rule allow for and a followup part of
the conver ation that we had had um you
could submit such a request that doesn't
make the person an employee so that was
something you said that just because
they apply for a waiver doesn't
automatically reclassify it's an
interesting question so for the purposes
of minimum of if you look at the at the
800 rules I think at
803 uh the which talks about exemptions
it makes clear that that individuals
participating and again because there's
a section of the statute that also
applies to disabled individuals but
students in an approved progr in a
program approved under 805 are not going
to be considered employees for the
purposes of 279 and
27542 so the the sections that are
applicable towards wage payment minimum
wage and wage payment um so for those
purposes I don't think they they um
would qualify as employees it would not
be counted and I guess just
and so to clarify let's imagine a
situation where there's no compensation
whatsoever they're an RA but it's purely
voluntary so if somebody were to just
ask you is this an employee you'd say no
because it it doesn't mean it but in
that case if a university said you know
we heard that Ra's need to waiver so
we're going to we're going to ask for
that that doesn't necessarily change the
landscape you
can the fact that they ask for a waiver
doesn't automatically mean that oh now
you need a waiver
because you ask for it
that and and I I seem to recall with
them what you wrote in the email was
there's no harm in putting a waiver in
place oh without knowing whether it's
necessary there there's never any harm
in any employer filing for one um there
are certainly circumstances where uh ERS
outside of the univ University system
file an application with the department
for the subminimum or no wage payment
approval and the department screens the
application and says this is not a
position that rises to the level of
employment um you know it's not needed
so there's no harm in ever putting it
forward that that was what uh I meant in
saying you know you can always you can
always do that anybody can file with on
receipt the Department's going to look
at it and screen it and assess you know
is it something that's appropriate to be
here you know is it something that falls
within the Department of Labor's purview
if it is a scenario where okay um you
know there is the that the employment
factor is there do you meet the criteria
through the application there's some
kind of practical learning experience
that issue because again it can't just
be I don't want to pay minimum wage and
that's my basis for applying we're
looking is there some kind of practical
um learning experience component
associated with that that and if that's
there then the department can approve it
and again now the entity with whom the
student is is providing that service for
has an exception to paying you know the
minimum wage um or the or can pay no
wage so the there's like essentially an
exception to the requirements to pay
minimum wage uh that comes with that
approval
ran I think there's several points that
uh need to be made here um first one is
what we're just hearing on this waiver
through the Department of Labor seems
like it might resolve the issue um in
and of itself without any legislative
change um number two um the bill as
presented
removes um the employment um definition
from five different sections of
Statute way more than we could possibly
need
um number three
I don't like removing um employee rights
um from anybody ever so that that gives
me a problem with the bill from from the
get-go But
continuing um this um in in our hearing
we heard from UNH no students but we did
hear from UNH we heard from Dartmouth
the four um Ras who came to testify um
and we heard about um Plymouth
um so we've got
information um for three different
schools we have no information for the
rest of the colleges in New Hampshire
this bill if um passed would affect all
colleges in New Hampshire some of them
being um priv would be private sector
employees some of them would be public
sector
employees um what we found out very
clearly is that Plymouth UNH and
Dartmouth had very different systems of
compensation for Ras um and um I would
guess only a guess but I would guess
that if
we heard from all of the other colleges
we would find quite a few more um
methods of compensation um but we have
no idea what they are so my suggestion
is if we do anything now there are
inevitably going to be unintended con
consequences for some of the colleges
who don't even know this is
happening um so
um I'll just put it out there because I
don't like taking employee rights away
from anybody itl sounds really good to
me
um but if that's not the path this would
absolutely need further study before we
could go forward with anything and I
think um those who have concerns can
work with the Department of Labor on the
potential for a waiver um if they're
concerned about the minimum wage aspects
of this um so
so all of your points are well made and
at the beginning at least somewhere in
my head that first point you made is
where I wanted to focus because you you
make a really good point if in fact the
existing situation given the change in
the rules are going to satisfy what
we're trying to
satisfy then then the subcommittee can
tell that the committee that well
there's no need to update the law at
this point because it's working and and
and I can clearly see the issue with
minimum wage that that is clearly a
problem for um Ras um because I think
some of them put in a little bit of time
some of them put in a lot of time and um
um if you can resolve that piece I I
think I think we're done here and and
I'll I'll say the Deputy Commissioner
mentioned this but I'll I'll repeat
it the the the law that she cited the
22A and the rules that result from that
are not limited exclusively to to
minimum wage which to me so the
department can say you have a couple of
issues here one is the minimum wage one
is maybe the overtime provision uh
they could identify multiple issues that
then they can grant a waiver for and I'm
going to just jump in and clarify just
to make sure that it is clear if I
wasn't clear earlier the waiver or
exemption that stems through the 27922
daa and lab um administrative rule 805
sector um is exclusive to to payment of
wages so minimum wage payment of wages
record keeping related to wages um it
does not extrapolate necessarily to the
Discrimination sections to the workers
compensation sections um yeah yes
excellent clarification because that is
was also part of yes your question so um
for for the moment I'd like to
continue the conversation that we
started and where I'm focusing is what
are things today now that this rues in
effect and how much does it already
resolve
and um then then we'll go from there I'm
not sure if it comes down to a
disagreement over some of your
other what needs to be in this bill how
could you possibly disagree what how
could you possibly
disagree it might be outside the scope
of the subcommittee it might be a debate
to have next week in front of the full
commit that's I don't want to stay here
I I was kidding yes okay Mr chairman I
just had a quick question as it relates
to the
determination uh and I'm not a member of
this committee and I appreciate the uh
uh the opportunity to speak uh the
question I have is is if somebody files
for determination by the do for a class
of workers is there any do work the
workers have a standing in in those
discussions can they argue uh submit
some some kind of testimony relative to
to that particular decision being made
so is it a one-sided thing I guess is
what I'm saying there there's
involvement with the the
um like the individuals are notified so
it's not just a one-sided a program
files an application or a school or
whomever is submitting files and
application and the the the
individual who is is in the learning
opportunity um program is completely cut
out of it
so they're they're
aware so it's not it's not I wouldn't
call it one-sided I would not say that
it's like it's not a communication Just
Between the department and the The
Entity so that it's a surprise to the
person who's participating they they are
aware and may participate in the I mean
partic it this isn't one of those
processes where the Department's having
meetings necessarily I mean applications
are filed written communication goes
back and forth um so I I don't I would
not color it as the the student
individual is completely cut out of it
and then it's just like oh I was
anticipating getting paid and now I'm
not getting paid they have notification
of it uh they receive copies of the
application approval they're seeing the
they're they have awareness of that
process I'd have to maybe solidify with
our uh the specific individuals who are
processing these applications how
granular that contact contact can get
and I think that depends on the nature
of what submitted in any types of
questions that may be raised or if
somebody if they're aware that a
program's been submitted contacts us to
say hey I have qualms about that I think
it can depend on the scenario but it but
it's not one where the participant is
just they have no awareness that it's
going on it's not they're not completely
cut out of
it a just a couple of points
representative Sullivan Debbie scary the
executive director from the New
Hampshire college and university council
is here and she has kind of scanned all
of the colleges in the state if you're
interested to to know how those Ras are
compensated I want to I want to try to
be clear
um we we are not we don't want to take
rights away from our Ras we want to be
able to compensate
them with a sizable credit to their bill
so they can participate in residential
college
experience that those are not those
credits on their bill are not taxed so
it's not considered a wage and the
RAS do not track time and I think you
heard that from the Dartmouth Ras even
though they get a stipend they're not
tracking time and and of itself there's
some conflict there
so our effort is to try to allow the RAS
to get free room and
board for their participation in the
program not tax we're really trying to
thread the needle I guess under the
usdol guidelines but still want to be
compliant with New Hampshire state law
and we had found again at Plymouth that
we need to we need to start all the RAS
would need to start tracking time and so
when we reached out to the New Hampshire
college and university Council and they
scanned the the colleges in the state we
found the same situation that folks
aren't tracking time what do we need to
do to comply so that's what got us where
we are today and I want to throw
something in because I started this out
by saying well if you went to US
Department of Labor their answer would
be it
depends and um specifically I have that
section from their book up uh on the
screen so those Ras they say the
students are not employees on under the
act under the Labor Act if they receive
renumeration in the form of reduced
rumor board charges freeuse of telephone
tuition credits and the like so some of
the circumstances we've heard you'd look
at this and you'd say you know what do
is not going to exempt them they might
say well what is in the like it isn't
there's something outside of this list
but it's like this list so so I think
it's not as clearcut as in all cases
that well US Department of Labor would
say absolutely not an employee and now
we have a state issue I I think in each
case and as we say it it it's going to
vary widely it's going to depend on the
details um and yes there is a slightly s
different process federal and state to
consider those
details on the other hand there is a
process federal and state to take those
details into
account and part of the qu but hopefully
to come to the right
answer and part of the question that if
we can come to that today is are are we
able to come to the right answer are
there cases where we're not able to come
to the right answer and if not why
not oh
I guess I just reiterate that where we
are is uh looking at a bill that removes
rights from five different um areas of
the statutes and and that I'm I would
say for right now forget the bill what I
want to look happy and and let's look
at what is what exists right now because
it has
changed since we've we've been here in
this term the rules have been adapted
and it if there was an issue two years
ago that may not be an issue now so what
I'd like to First understand is where
are we today and we might be happy where
we are today we might be unhappy where
we are today but only in once we know
that should we consider well what do we
do about it
so I I agree with that there are
problems with the bill as written
um but there's no point in figuring out
those problems or even debating those
problems if we all agree that it it's
not the path that we need to
take
fine so I don't
know uh did I cut you off on something
that you perceived as a question that
you didn't get to answer I don't believe
so but if so I've
forgotten and and what what what I'm
hearing is in terms of where we are
today is we have rules in place that
give uh
the colleges and universities um some
options with regard to clarifying um
exactly where their Ra's uh stand in
terms of employment status Unemployment
uh and other wage issues and so from
your standpoint part of it was a
question you weren't
sure how that might work and whether it
was practical did this
discussion well enlightened the
situation it enlightened but we I still
don't know how the the process will
actually work and hopefully those
waivers would be approved that's but you
apply for a waiver so those need to be
approved just a little point of
clarification on the unemployment I I
didn't I didn't mean to say unemployment
R Ras are already as soon as I said that
I thought back to the Senate um uh
hearing where um Deputy Commissioner
labors made it very clear that U you
know we we you've got no issues here
it's already excluded right so sorry
sorry I just
misspoke so one question I asked the
department which is sort of where you're
headed is are there
outstanding problems where an employer
is asked thinks they should have a
waiver and the department thinks they
shouldn't and it it has not been
resolved and the answer was to me was
you weren't aware of any globally I I
was understanding the question to be in
line with
universities yes so you know globally I
I didn't dig you know overarchingly um
but as far as uh the department as far
as I'm aware from my understanding from
communicating with the division that is
responsible for uh taking in and
reviewing and monitoring these
applications to date we've not had any
filed by any college or university and
so there are no outstanding disputes
because we simply have not had one uh
had one for this type of position let me
ref that I I think there are
universities that have um various
programs or entities that have filed
them uh for practical experience that
may involve a university and and I think
that's accurate um but not 100% sure but
there have been none filed for an RA
type of position so we don't have any
for Ari types of positions so um and
again there are I know around the state
within the university system um we
provide free room and board but there's
not a stipend
and that free room and board
aligns right now let me back up when we
had the inspection at pouth Plymouth we
were providing a stipend with room and
board we stopped the stipend because of
the inspection and with the time
tracking and all of that so um I guess
my question for the Department is with
the waiver for institutions that are
providing free room and board with no
stipend
that I think aligns with that us do
paragraph do those institutions need to
apply for the
waiver it's a good question so I I I'm
never comfortable giving an absolute
answer and saying no they never have to
because it it it does you know depend if
you don't have um a
relationship with the individual who is
providing whatever service it is such
that that it would kind of fall within
that employee employer relationship
where wages would be paid you you might
not need one right cuz it's it's
intended to provide an exemption or a
waiver to a requirements to pay wages
for time that's being worked so you
might not but again it really depends on
a number of different factors
well right as you was speaking I'm sorry
having a conversation with Deputy
Commissioner actually if memory serves
the the waiver also part of our other
problem we were having was so okay so
now we have an RA that's not an employee
that they don't get a W2 for the value
of their room and board they don't track
their time but they work in the
bookstore now we do have an employee
relationship and so the waiver
also helps with
that uh that that was another problem
when we were working through all of
these
and sorry to talk over you I got very
excited I think that's where some of the
the rule change kind of came from I
think that's part of what we heard from
the University system so again if you
have under the prior iteration of the
rule if you had a student like an RA and
there was interest or intent to have the
ra position we'll say met the you know
the stien still there it met the
elements or requirements for an employee
employer relationship but the um
university is interest you know we don't
want to pay the minimum wage we want
exception to Pro to pay minimum wage
track hours we want an exception to all
of that uh under prior iterate and the
person also the ra also had a job full
paying job in the bookstore were very
you know that's also an employment
relationship uh agreement was you're
going to get $ 725 an hour or $10 an
hour whatever it is that gets paid under
prior iteration of the rule the program
couldn't be approved because you don't
you could not the individual the
participant couldn't hold dual rules we
altered the rule to allow individuals
participating in Practical experience
programs to be able to hold kind of both
you can participate in a practical
experience program and not get paid for
it because the department has approved
through the mechanisms in place uh
either no wage rate if that's what's
been approved but also have a you know
full paying job where you're getting the
minimum wage or higher than that if
that's what the job you know is agreed
for so now both both can be fulfilled so
they would not conflict with one another
anymore um I think that was the our
understanding of of some of the concern
that the university had so altered the
rule to allow for that and again not
just for the University system but for
any you know employer who may have a
similar
scenario right and and and if I can
clarify that issue has been resolved by
the rule change regardless of whether
there's any waivers or anything is that
correct the rule change is a section of
rules that's specific to the waiver so I
I I think it does apply to the waiver so
what the rule change did was it allowed
for an
employer uh an entity to have a
individual participating in Practical
learning experience and we'll I'll stick
with the ra theme because that's kind of
what we're talking about here that was
an approved program practical learning
experience is coming through that an
application's been filed the department
has looked at the application yes we
agree leadership and um community
service and all of that is going to
qualify under uh as practical experience
through this program so we're going to
give the approval to pay less than the
minimum wage or no no wage you can also
ask for no wage so we'll give the
approval to pay no wage that provides
the exemption to the requirements under
279 and
2752 the definition of employee under U
I'm sorry
27542 uh in all those attendant pieces
um but if that same individual who's
participating or series of individuals
if you have multiple raas who are
participating in the Practical learning
experience for no wage are not barred or
precluded from holding a job in the
bookstore whereas under the rule it
caused a problem you couldn't do it so
we adjusted the rule to allow for both
to happen for the individual
participating in the program
simultaneously without interfering with
the paying job with the routinely paying
job that nobody's seeking waver or
exception to and I'll briefly
editorialize I
think as I've learned more about this
there's an advantage to this waiver
process that we've set up in that they
can look at the details that have we
said they're going to vary every
situation is going to be a little
different it also allows the department
to say hey we've never seen anything
like this before let's let's figure this
out
whereas changing the
law is a one-sized fits all change so
and I I think it's important to let this
um rule change um work itself through to
find out how it's going to function um
because we've had no applications from
this type of um situation so
um uh I'm not sure if there's a
mechanism by well I think because we've
got folks here who are intimately
involved with the uh uh universities and
colleges in um New Hampshire that they
will become aware of the waiver
situation let's let it
work so I don't know if you want you
have a reaction to that I would also um
whether you do or not miss sky is that
um if you have any kind of input to that
looking at the broader range of
universities and you're welcome to take
another microphone so we don't have to
swap
seats did you have anything first I
didn't want to cut you
off uh no other than um we don't know
how the waiver process is going to work
uh it just again the rule was just
adopted last fall after our our fall
semester had started and we because this
legislation was moving through the
process actually the change in the
rule the Genesis of that was the
University system the New Hampshire
college and university Council working
with the Department of
Labor be at the same time um we are
working with the sponsor because as you
can tell from the
conversation the there are a lot of
needles to thread here in in in hopes of
continuing to
provide our you know our students
um you know a way to have free room in
board not taxed but have another job on
campus not track time um
so will the waiver process work I don't
have any reason to think it won't I will
say it will get extremely
administratively burdensome if we need
to f F separate waiver applications for
every ra for every semester and there
was that was a question a couple months
ago so and I heard the answer is no I
believe you would have to I think there
can be an application filed sort of for
the the Practical experience program
itself now a list of participating
students will need to be maintained and
my understanding is that that will
rotate because it changes per semester
or something of that nature
um so long as that's maintained uh at
least annually the department would kind
of want to see the application refiled
just to assure that the program that has
been approved itself hasn't changed um
you know but but I I don't believe you
would need to file one per student that
would be I think I understand that would
be an administrative burden and that
would be a lot of paper for us to take
in as well and really what we're looking
at is the program um and who's
participating in the program so again
there's got to be a list but you don't
have to if if there's a hundred students
on the list you can it's almost like an
attachment to the program as opposed to
one per person and and again in in the
specific example within the university
system when there's where there's no
stipend paid so there's no
W2 again I'm so we're still considering
them
employees contrary to the federal
guidelines because applying for a
waiver in and of itself if in and of
itself they're defined as employees you
wouldn't apply for waiver if they
weren't employees
and I'll I'll repeat what you said and
then you can add so not
necessarily
that they may be they may not be if you
just said I don't think I need a waiver
are they employees the department would
think about that and they would answer
one way or another if you instead said
you know I'm going to need a waiver I'm
not sure if they're employees the
department may say you know we looked at
this but they're they aren't even
employees to begin with so you don't
need this waiver there's
no this was the explanation there's no
downside to saying do we need a waiver
let me file the information so you can
evaluate it they may say yes we they're
employees and we Grant you the waiver
they may say they weren't employees to
begin with you didn't need the waiver
and I I think what's become clear is
that um there are a lot of different
entities out there who are evaluating
the employment status of these folks um
there's the um Fair labor standards act
there's the nlrb there's the plrb
there's the Department of Labor um
there's the um Department of Employment
Security they've already uh weighed in
um so there's there's a lot of different
folks who are going to make this
determination and
um I will say it again this bill deals
with five different
and that it's interesting we'll discuss
that for a moment because it does make a
certain point that there are and we know
this having worked on labor for a long
time there are different definitions of
employees throughout the statutes we've
we made an effort a few years ago to
make try to get them so they match we
still haven't and here is and here is an
example of you when you
if you ask the question is this an
employee or not well relative to what
and there's any number of statutes that
may the answer may come different out
different depending
on what the Contex and we and we know
that on a federal level the nlrb views
it one way and the LSA views it a
different way and and that was by the
way that was another thing I read I'll
I'll bring it up I didn't know whether I
don't know if we want to go here but I
I'll bring it up because I did I did
take the time to read it the
Dartmouth nlrb petition on the
basketball team and I was interested I
think you probably know because I
remember your questions from the
hearing it was an issue are these
students employees and the university
had one opinion that the and
the application for organization had
another and what the nlrb did was they
didn't go to federal law they didn't go
to state law they used dictionary
definitions of what an employment
relationship is and they went through
and say are do these things
exist and I don't think we were ever
going to resolve the the issue of I
we're not going to make all this stuff
uh align right and so in my opinion what
whatever we did we wouldn't affect that
Dartmouth decision because it's a a
national level and they didn't refer to
laws so changing the laws shouldn't
impact that decision now on a state
level I am not aware that our PB has
gone through this issue of what's an
employee what isn't if they did we don't
know
what we don't know what how they
consider it so attempting to anticipate
a change in law and how that might
impact a future decision I think is a
Fool's game we we just have no way to
predict this unless somebody put in a
law and said the plb shall decide this
which that is not leader
so yes I'm I'm agreeing with you and I
think the point is well made that this
bill shows
the what happens when we're trying to
Define empy mment as a as a a singular
thing when in fact in existing law in
existing practice it always depends on
the context and each College might be
different
exactly but this if I
could there's a and I think you've
expressed it representative Solan this
this takes place people rights but it it
also seems to me that um it kind of uh
creates this um class of
employees who can be who are out of the
employment
environment and yet still in the college
and university doing all of this work as
was described by the doop students um
and without some kind of standing in
this process they are really just
employee it's not employees they just
people who can be um I I I'm I'm going
to say this that they can be
overworked they can be made to work
24-hour shifts as has been described and
what we're doing is we're taking away
potentially taking away their ability to
be able to advocate for themselves in
this whole process and even in the case
of the of a waiver there is no standing
that employees currently have employers
file there is this kind of system where
maybe they'll get a hold of 100
employees maybe who knows if they even
though this is going on they come back
and bang it's it's over so this is this
leaves people and workers in our RA in
this kind of crazy little spot where
they have no standing no that somebody
else is making the decisions that that
affects their lives in a very big way
and I think that if broadly that's also
a an issue that we can't resolve so for
example when I was an undergradu
graduate I had a class where we had to
work on some stuff so in some ways I was
doing work but nobody paid me I was
paying for the privilege of attending
the class where I would fix a a car
engine um so where does that fall into
place and if you if you don't have the
ability to say you know there's a gray
area between a student listening to a
lecture and a person who's who's being
paid to come in 40 hours a week and do
labor I think we can we can
never um appreciate the full spectrum of
what goes on in a learning environment
so except to the extent that that what
was described to us uh is a situation
where these people on duty 24 hours a
day this is this is this is testimony
yes so and again I
um I don't believe that was yes the
issue I don't believe that's the issue
that this
subcommittee will fruitfully discuss
another thing that I heard was
Dartmouth did not contest that there was
an employee relationship there there was
some disagreement on how to define that
relationship and this is what I heard
the student saying but there wasn't a
disagreement that there was a
relationship so I don't believe there
was any disagreement between the raas
and Dartmouth and the administration at
Dartmouth they're they're okay well I
would add though they said they're not
tracking their time and yes and that's
exactly what got Plymouth in trouble so
there's no that if they're not tracking
their time then there's no way to
determine whether or not they're earning
minimum wage and that's why we're here
but they might be well advised to seek
the
waiver I had a question I wasn't clear
if you represent only the public
university system or if you represent
the private as well I I'm my apologies
um I represent the university system of
New Hampshire which is Plymouth Kean and
UNH and Miss skiri is the executive
director of the New Hampshire college
and university Council that includes all
the colleges public and private in the
state except Dartmouth that's
interesting thank
you so representative
Kum oh okay and if I can I'm so sorry to
to jump in and interrupt and it's a
little bit tangental to representative
McKenzie's um comments but just so that
I've adequately explained uh some of the
application process because I didn't
walk through you know every step uh in
the process part of what the department
screaming for it's outlined in the rules
itself and I'm happy to share a full
copy of the rules with the committee if
that's helpful to look at them in their
entirety and I did the I sent an email
around to the members of the
subcommittee that had that link in the
attachment okay um I can I yeah the link
send it to the full committee link to
the full rule is there um but some of
what is screened on you know for
eligibility purposes is one of the
requirements in obtaining one of these
waivers you can't be dis placing you
know the the regular Workforce so no
employer or or educational institution
or post-secondary school can put forward
an application and say well I don't want
to hire regular employees anymore I just
want to have practical experience
Learners so we're just going to get rid
of our paid positions and apply for
subminimum no minimum wage rate so again
it's meant to be kind of a learning you
know practical learning experience it's
not displacing the workforce it's it's
so there are certain standards that are
embedded within the application process
uh
you know if it's Youth and these are
college students we're talking about so
the youth labor walls are not going to
apply but certainly you know
applications come in for youth you know
assuring that we're not doing dangerous
things in violation of hazardous orders
and things of that nature so there are
some um there are some criteria that are
built in that is evaluated on receipt
that the department is looking at as
part of the program so I just I don't
know if that's helpful at all I think
it's a little tangential to your
commentary representative Mackenzie but
I just wanted that to to be clear and
known
and and to be clear I think this
legislature has a role in seeing whether
a Department administra administrative
process is working or not working um my
suggestion is it's kind of outside the
scope of this meeting here
today so um I think your points are well
made and uh to the extent that they go
to what we should recommend on this bill
they're they're definitely relevant but
um there's a bigger picture here that
you're you're talking about much bigger
if we needed to to seek more information
to understand that there aren't there
isn't a coverage of Labor rights for
those employees I mean I'd be open to to
interim study I mean if that's something
we thought we could bring the interested
parties to um um to talk about that I
don't know how you feel but I mean I
wouldn't oppose an interim study and to
participate in
that and and we'll let's come back to
that but let's get there pretty soon and
yes so but before we do I asked uh you
to come up and if we're missing a
perspective that's outside of
um no I'm very happy to share it's very
nice to be here I'm Debbie skiri I um
lead the new hampsh college and
university Council represents as um
Kathy preventure has said um all the
colleges and universities in New
Hampshire um with the exception of
Dartmouth um Thomas Moore college and
Magdalene College as well so um we
represent most most everyone so um in
preparation for this um this
conversation and so forth I reached out
to the colleges and universities um to
put together sort of a quick chart of
sort of where people were at and exactly
as you have said um every it seems like
every school is a little bit different
everyone seems to be approaching it in a
way that works for their own institution
and in line with what they um believe is
is the right way to go so we have you
know folks that um are um identifying
their resident assistance as quote
unquote student employees which they're
very quick to say would be characterized
um like temporary part-time employees um
we have folks that you know say no
they're not employees at all um um they
are being reimbursed some of them with
with room um they're boarded um some uh
discounted meal plan or maybe even a
full meal plan there are some stiens
involved too um and uh the other piece
of that is I could find no evidence of
anyone um really tracking hours um as
far as this particular position goes but
I'm very happy to answer any questions
and happy to share the the data that
I've pulled together um whatever would
be most
helpful if um is that data do you have a
a right it's still like a little chart
to make it really easy I'd be more than
happy to share
that all sure thank you oh
good and if there's an extra
representative love would you like one
of these yes there's one right here for
you oh got one there all right sorry we
I will put it in the full committee F or
the yeah the bill
folder this isting representative are we
did do you have a we're kind of going in
a certain direction if there's a another
okay so one of the things I'll Echo um
what representative Selvin was saying
this committee has a tradition of when
we like the way things work without our
involvement we like to stay out of it
and what I'm hearing today is well we
may not be able to know whether it's
working the way we like it right
now it's might be worth giving it a
chance to see if the process works as
intent
right now before we go in and and make
additional
changes I I agree um there's effectively
a rule a set of rules that have been uh
amended um that have not been um
utilized and it sounds to me like that
may very well take care of um much of
what is a problem um if those rules
come up short and there are still some
issues
um let's hear about it next year year
after something like that but uh um it
sounds to me like that's something that
ought to be explored first before we um
go in with a sledgehammer and um make
massive
changes and with respect to the interim
study I guess it's a timing issue if we
thought we were going to learn a bunch
of stuff before the end of the year an
interim stud would be a vehicle to
provide that report the alternative is
to you know the filing period's not that
far off for the next
legislature that's that's what the
interim stud is going to do anyway
anyway it's going to either recommend
for additional legislation or not
um I'm not sure that that accomplishes a
great deal doesn't say I guess it could
be a legislation of this nature or
something like that but bottom line is
um no no one has to file that bill um
someone can file the bill without the
recommendation or in opposition to the
the
recommendation exactly and I guess what
I'm saying is if we really thought there
was going to be a bunch of information
pouring in this summer interim study
would be a great way to collect it um
I'm not sure that's what we're looking
at and
it's at any time that a deficiency in
the process is identif ified a bill of
this nature can be filed to
correct what what is perceived to be
wrong at that
time I I've already suggested that itl
would be um something I could easily
support all right so I
will uh write down that you have made a
motion of itl Okie do
and before I before I continue on and
ask for a second um I know there were I
kind of picked the people that that I
wanted to hear from if there was someone
that came here today and had uh
something important they wanted to
discuss I don't want to cut you off at
the same time this this is not a hearing
we not been there done that we don't
need to do it again okay agreed agreed
but I didn't want I didn't want anybody
to feel like they came all the way down
here and we didn't want they're just
here to watch that's okay so is there a
second to representative San's motion
all
right
um and I always write this in the wrong
every time I write it and in an
amendment line instead of on the bill on
yeah so
um so is there any discussion on the
recommendation that representative Solan
has
made you're just going to leave us in
[Laughter]
suspense all right well I'm going to
deal with this I'll ask you to vote
first
[Laughter]
representative yes yes n itl I'll say
yes yes and R yes all right so we will
recommend to the committee itl and
explain um what we have learned about
the rule process and why we're
recommending in a much shorter version
yes maybe I'll let you explain it since
you made the motion I I have a habit of
getting oh that makes sense off track
here all right thank you very much for
uh coming and participating and and
teaching us about the process
just a reminder there is another
subcommittee meeting at 2 p.m. I'm not
on no you're not none of us are well he
might he is
but plent time
home this a very interesting topic so
you guys went through like in that um
section on like for example the minimum
wage there's all those weird categories
you know what I'm talking about do you
remember
this
e
e e
uh good question uh so um it it's not
very not exactly clear at least to me
what happened in the Senate um the
department wasn't
um other than being um at the initial
hearing on the the bill uh to increase
the Senate bill to increase benefits
which was much different than the
amended version we didn't have much
involvement after that uh so unlike with
House labor where we had a lengthy
hearing ing a lot of questions were
asked and a lot of information was
provided with regards to how the current
U pay Matrix works for eligibility for
unemployment and how much you have to
earn in order to be eligible for each
weekly benefit amount and the impact
that the proposals would have we didn't
really have that opportunity in the
Senate um so um we did have a
conversation with with the sponsor
Senator Perkins quoka and um you know
she was optimistic that maybe something
would be able to be done in the next
session uh but there seemed to be quite
a bit of resistance to um doing anything
with with benefits in in this session
but again I don't know the specifics of
of why that was
yeah 2007 was it one
so the legislation
iev am ofy
that
comes I think there some discussion
yester the amount of money
state has to pay
P that to
and I I was able to run those numbers if
you want me to quickly go over them and
I don't I'm I'm not I'm not certain what
the threshold is but I do know from um a
like a a pure fiscal note perspective
and looking at impact to State and
Municipal uh spending uh the state as an
employer when we looked at 2023 there
were um just over
$142,000 in unemployment benefits paid
to former state employees so executive
legislative judicial that does not
include the university system that does
not include the community college system
it's just the three branches of
government um when we had looked at the
impact that the Senate proposal would
have
to existing benefit payments that was an
increase of
26% overall so if you took 26% of what
was paid out um to the state's former
employees in 2023 that would be about um
just shy of a
$37,000 increase I think that exceeds
the the thresholds that people were
talking
about correct that does not include
County or local employment
no doubt that
but I think that I
think inrease
um so the the both proposals is amended
both of them increase the amount of
benefits going out right so that in and
of itself has an impact on an employer's
experience rating so when you increase
the amount of benefits we use that to
calculate what their experience is their
experience translates into a rate at
which they pay when we look at the fun
balance reduction thresholds which
determin when an employer gets
reductions to their earned rate the
proposed bill would not have an impact
um on those um because the the Senate
proposal um does seek to raise the fund
balance uh reduction thresholds
currently it's at 250 million uh 350 and
400 million to get the Half Point full
point point and a half reduction
the Senate proposal would increase that
to
um yeah I have it right
here the the Senate proposal would go so
instead of 250 350 400 it would go 300
450 and that change in and of itself
would not have an impact on employers uh
tax rates from the perspective
perspective of what they're forecasted
to get for a fund balance reduction for
each quarter through the end of
2025 and that's due to the current
balance of the trust fund being you know
we we're hovering right now around 400
million um and so what we're forecasting
the fund to
maintain um is basically a continuation
of a 1% reduction and the proposal in
the senate in those threshold s and what
the forecasted balances are to be would
not um cause a change to
that uh point I want to say
6% uh we're down
to First 14 so uh we are at as of Q3 of
2023 average uh um experience rated
employer was at
.57 uh that is lower than where they
were prior to the
pandemic it's probably
top uh bottom three bottom five in terms
of lowest UI tax burdens in the country
B
a
uh the the house version would have a
higher
in would cause a higher increase in
benefits but they're they're close right
with single digit percentages apart so
the house bill 1522 is amended would be
a 32% increase in payouts looking at
2023 experience and uh the Senate bill
as amended would be a
26% increase in looking at the same
experience period um raw dollars
we're
talking 6
million uh for the Senate and third and
uh 9 million for the house version the
the reason for that and I can confirm
those amounts the reason for that is the
Senate version adds new tiers but it
does not increase the existing
tiers the house version increases the
existing tiers and adds new tiers
just
the difference between them um the the
number the the raw dollars I wasn't
certain of so the Senate Amendment would
cause an increase of 6.8 million which
was a 26% increase over what was paid
out in
2023 the house bill 1522 with the
amendment would cause an 8.4 almost $8.5
million increase which was a
33% change over what was paid out
however the house version the amendment
did stagger that implementation over 3
years so and the way that it did that
was it introduced the new benefit tiers
gradually over each of those three so
then in the first year was an 18%
increase the second year was a 27%
increase and then in the the third year
Allin and going forward was a 33% not in
addition to the 27 but 6% more so fully
baked it was a
33% increase and again the reason for
that um was with the adjustment that the
house version did to the existing tiers
so
my motion the motion should be that we
accept this bill
yeah I think I have
uh I'm looking at 202
24-5
61h that's it
yep replaces the whole thing
go
am e
that
function no I I don't think so because
of the the language that the Senate
included that allows the department
to um conduct rulemaking to make sure
that in the instances that uh someone is
allowed to exclusively look for remote
work and continue to be eligible it's
going to be in an industry that offers a
sufficient amount of remote work
opportunities so our concern was not
that remote work is is some sort of fad
and it's it's going to go away it's very
much here to stay
but for over half of the New Hampshire
Workforce which is comprised of service
related Industries such as health care
manufacturing construction retail
Hospitality someone coming out of that
industry filing for unemployment and
looking for work in that industry if
they were to limit themselves to remote
work that would not be uh u a real
adequate work search when that's not a a
very um um abundant
opportunity within those sectors so we
want the ability to Define that and have
you know make sure that when you're
looking exclusively for remote work that
it's within an industry that offers a
sufficient amount of remote work
opportunity
um the bill doesn't get into that the
the the language which um it cleans up
the statute this is this was a a piece
of uh statute that originated back to
the Social Security Act um so what we
put in here was an individual should not
be eligible if they're limiting
themselves to work within the home
unless work to be conducted within the
individual individual's home offers a
reasonable expectation of substantial
employment opportunities based upon
rules adopted by the
commissioner
e
e e